all right Barbie yeah Barbie uh where'd
you grow up where are you from where's
Jim
um I grew up in Fontana
and yeah
and uh tell me about your family growing
up you had Mom and Dad yes um
well yeah I grew up I went to Boston
home I was with my mom and I went to
foster home and at what age
I was probably like eight like eight
years old my mom
she lives on um like drugs like Red
Devils I guess it makes you sleep so she
fell asleep in the county building and
we were like running around eating off
the floor and stuff so they took it like
we were being neglected and then they
took us away and it was me
and my brother and my sister and we went
to this little like Center place where
they um take the kids and find places
and then they separated us and then
I stayed in there for like a year I mean
yeah in the Foster for a year and then
my dad he got me out the Foster room
and then I moved to Fontana
awesome
what kind of kid were you in high school
um
uh a guy I guess I mean I don't know I
didn't have a lot of friends like girls
didn't like me like so I used to like
hang with a lot of boys like I didn't
have too many white girls as friends
because they don't like me how do you
describe your childhood in general
it was good all the way I mean yeah when
my dad took me I got me out to foster
home it was I had a good life my dad
he's a conductor for the railroad
[Music]
and I'm the only child for my daddy but
not for my mom
um my mom she's Korean and she was born
in South Korea
and she was abandoned in like in a rice
paddy field in South Korea so
around the wartime like because she was
born in 51 so it's like I guess that was
around the wartime right the Korean War
yeah yeah and her parents they they
abandoned her I guess you know like in
movies you see like they leave their
children somewhere safe and then they
just never end up coming back for him
and then she went to orphanage and then
some Americans I guess for like ten
thousand dollars they brought her they
brought her like they adopted her but
they had to pay for you know and so
she's Americanized yeah
are your parents still alive yeah my
daddy stays in
um
where is it um Apple Valley
no Victorville that's the same thing
you know where Apple Valley or Victor
I've heard of them they're way out there
yeah and my mom stays in Bellflower
yeah who are you closer to my mom your
mom yeah my daddy's like
he's he's like real strict like you
don't believe in being like all like
being ghetto and like he was just real
straight slice to run away from him to
be and watch thinking
not I don't I don't know if you call it
ghetto like you know like tattoos and I
thought I just thought it was like
it was cool and it wasn't I didn't get
me nowhere
being
being defiant or like yeah
not listening to my dad like I would be
priced in a Corvette somewhere like
yeah did you graduate high school yeah I
pregnant and all my dad made me still go
to school and um yeah pregnant what age
if I was 14 14. but I went to Paris how
you know where is that embarrassed you
don't know where Paris is not this you
know I know p-e-r-r-i-s
yeah yeah the city right yes yeah
yes you can go to Paris France no
no
but when that moved me far away like
you're out in the desert yeah he moving
me out way out there and
yeah made me live with some because he
didn't know about like girl like he
didn't know too much about girls stuff
like
because he was Raising Me by himself
like and you you raised your daughter
yeah
um no like I was young so I like she
left she went with her um her dad
she went on her death side of her family
and he got killed when she was three
years old
yeah like I don't know you believe in
karma I do okay yeah so like he um like
right before he got killed like he had
robbed my dad he and my dad like so one
day I went to go spend the night at my
dad's house and he was like oh let me
show you something and then he shows me
a video and then it's like the videos of
my baby's father and his friend breaking
into the house and stuff and then he's
like
um
I can take I can put them in jail or
like whatever but I'm gonna let God
handle it he's like I'm not gonna do
nothing and then my daughter birthday
was coming up soon too and um
yeah he robbed them and stuff and then
so when I went to my daughter birthday
party and confronted him he was like
[ __ ] I didn't do [ __ ] your daddy lying
like and he had the camera my dad's
because my dad does professional
photography too like on the side he has
cameras like and stuff
um like taping the birthday party and
stuff
but he got killed like a couple of days
later I'm not saying my dad did it but
like I think his apartment like you have
your own baby's Grandpa right yeah your
own daughter's grandpa is he in a gang
yeah he was from
um Pomona 357 yeah
his name was and dog
so when did you end up in the streets
when I ran when I like
when I had my baby so I was like 15. so
you've been in and out yeah since I was
15. yes I was running away and you got
introduce the prostitution when
um when I was when I ran away and I was
like 15. I was there and it was me and
my best friend we both ran away from um
Fontana to watts and so one day we we
didn't have money we got we was like we
got bored and so we took we got on the
Metro train the train um because
my mom her uh her baby's father I guess
she got four baby daddies
and they're all black but one of her
baby daddies are is from watts and so I
used to run away to be out there because
my mom was more she let me do anything
and she did my mom did drugs so
and we we did drugs together
she stole some of her boyfriends I
caught her sleeping with my my boyfriend
before because my mom she didn't age
like she didn't it took a long time for
her to look her age like because I don't
look 37 right no you don't you could be
like 20. yes so she used to steal my
boyfriend's like I would catch her
sleeping with him and stuff like Jerry
Springer stuff
yes so currently you're working you work
the streets or you work yeah I don't do
I'm too old for that like
like I I'm not saying I have went
but it was probably like
a year ago yeah I went but you're mostly
working the internet but yeah I like the
internet because
it's too cold out there and I'm lazy
yeah yeah all right
dangerous too right yeah
and I don't have a pimp or nothing no
I did before like you tricked you've had
things before yeah a well-known one his
name was um bird
he's from Gardena a lot of people a lot
of holes I'm like
what was your experience what was your
experience having a film but I got his
name tattooed because I was like one of
his bottom [ __ ] like
I got Bird right here with the wings
yeah oh yeah
um he how he tricked me and my friend
one day um so we we took the Metrolink
um to
so we end up getting off at the
something somewhere right there and we
start walking and we we come to the
liquor store that's right there on
Rosecrans or whatever and she's like 13
and I'm like probably 15. she was
younger than me so we just
yeah we got off and we just started
walking and we found a store we stood in
front of the store and then these two
guys they um pulled up and like one of
them had like this fur coat on so that
was looking like rapper says like he
wasn't thinking about no prostitute like
or because we grew up in Fontana like
around like it was like white people
racist stuff we didn't grow up around
like gang banging and you know La stuff
getting that pimps and hoes out there
huh you didn't have temps and hoses yeah
we didn't so
okay so we didn't think nothing of it
like we thought they were like probably
rappers or something so
they um had only a little flashy little
you know stuff and they get out and then
they we stand in front of store they get
out go in and then buy some liquor and
then they come back out and then they
ask us like well we what was we doing
and we told them we just um we was bored
and we got lost or whatever so then they
was like well oh um it's a part we got a
party
um and you can make some money you ain't
even gotta have sex so he was like for
real and then we got in the car
then so um on the way to wherever he was
taking us he was like he's like we need
clothes we need this he's like oh no we
got we got everything I got everything
that you um that a girl needed or would
want to wear or whatever so we get there
and it's like a big house and we go in
he has his picture like big with his fur
coat on like with him in like a picture
of himself yeah on the wall so we're
looking like we really thinking he rap
or something so then he um as we walk in
through the house it's different girls
in each room it's like probably four or
five rooms and so we walk in and then he
we get to a one room and it's like it
has clothes and like all kind of stuff
so we looking through the clothes and we
never wear heels or like hoochie mama
clothes and we're like so we was like
but we put it we found something and
then put it on then he came back in
there and um almost Vivian
and he almost I mean he almost yeah he
asked us to write our address and name
down and so I was about to do it and
then my friend was like she's like no
she was like girl you stupid he might
try to come kill our family or like
something so we just wrote something
fake down but he made us write our stuff
down so then we got dressed and he was
like it was time to go to the party but
he told us we would just have to dance
so we got on these Hills and stuff and
we get in the van it's me him and my
friend my best friend and then the um
his friend we're only like 13 14 and
these These are grown men like they at
least probably was 30 something they
were older older guys and then so
on our way there we on our way there and
stuff we smoking weed and stuff and then
he then they get to like this gas
station and he opens the door and then
he pulls me out and then um we start
crying like you know I thought they was
about to run off with my friend like
because they kicked me out of the thing
so he um took when he put us put me out
the car
out the van he um had his number written
down already and this was when payphones
was out so he was like after you catch a
date call me and then he jumped he got
in the van I understand what that meant
like I just started crying like I just I
thought they were like just abandoned
and strandedness like we didn't
understand so then he took my friend and
then I see the the van stop and let her
out way at the other end and then we end
up walking to meet each other and then
we told I was like what do you tell you
she was like to call him after I um
after I got a date and wrote his number
down and put in the phone booth and then
so
um we ended up
we ended up we was cold so we and hungry
so we said forget it we just gonna we're
gonna do it so we I caught a date and
then she caught a date then we met back
up as soon as we got like all our dates
and we met back up a guy pulls up and
and um tells us to get in the car so we
get in the car and we're like all proud
of ourselves because we did a date right
it's probably for like a hundred dollars
so we just we felt like we did something
big he's like give us he's like give me
your money right he was like what and
then he was like give me your money and
then call when you and then call dude
and then do the same thing when you I'm
done
and we already understands those I
started crying and I gave him my money
and then she started crying she gave the
money to him and then he kid they kicked
he told us to get out catch another day
and then we'll we could come back and
and have fun and be and be cool so we
ended up catching another day and not
going back we just was like forget we we
was like he taught us like something you
know taught us a game like the game like
how to make money we just about to run
with it and we left
so like probably a couple of years later
I ran back into him the same guy and I
ended up really being like a hoe for him
he did not I got his name tattooed on me
and stuff and then she tried to come
back too but she she snuck some money
that this day that she came back it was
like a reunion you know and so she came
and she tried to make some money and he
went in there and um filled the tub up
with ice and cold water and was and was
I don't know if he put her in there
because I wasn't in the bathroom but he
she got I mean she ended up giving him
the money
because yeah
but I used to get like if I didn't want
I like because I'm a tomboy I was a
tomboy and I grew up my dad so I didn't
feel comfortable wearing like shorts or
dress skirts and so the first time he
made me wear it he [ __ ] I didn't want
to wear it I didn't want to wear the
shorts out and he um he beat me he well
yeah he beat me and then hung me over
like
um you know the Hacienda Motel like how
it's like really it's like you ever been
to the Hacienda it's a nice Motel okay
and hotel and
yeah is it in South Central
yeah I think it's I don't know I think
it's gardening like okay well it's a
nice well he hung me over the balcony he
was threatened to like drop me and then
I end up wearing the um shorts and stuff
yeah but you prefer to be without a pimp
yeah because I don't like to listen
but a lot of stuff happens to me out
there like I've been I've been kidnapped
and
raped I've been
um
I don't know my friend I had a um a
wifey she got killed and then she I
found out she was only like 14. she was
young but I was older at the time and I
didn't know she was like how she get
killed
um by a trick I guess because she used
to steal from him and she did used to
steal from and she just was found they
found her in
Orange County but she got found over
there by Jack In The Box like with her
head I mean they but they bust her head
over
and they just trying to save the pen
like RPM did it but we already know like
she used to steal from the tricks and
stuff so that's possibly could have been
will happen I don't know yeah
but like when the police would pick
picked me up and said they would show me
pictures of her and stuff and like try
to get me to snitch on them like you
know on our pimp he was like
I didn't say nothing I was like I I
believe he didn't do it like but he did
he did used to beat her ass like
when she would get like I guess out of
pocket
like talk backwards that's the word yeah
yeah
what was what what kind of drones do you
prefer
white right guys and yeah I like white
guys and Mexican guys
I don't really date black guys yeah I
hear that a lot
because all black guys are I look at him
as pants I don't know that's just how I
view them like are they like always
trying to hustle you yeah I thought I in
my my own life I don't date
I'm like
that's not my preference a black guy I
only date white and Mexican
because they know how to treat like they
know how to treat me and
yeah
Mexicans
especially the the price of ones like
they let me they do anything for me
yes this is uh does this work get to you
emotionally do you get depressed or when
angry or
does it affect you emotionally to do
this work yeah like I don't like doing
it um
yes like I don't that's probably why I
don't know I don't I'm strict like I
don't think and I don't think it
I don't know how to say I think it's
nasty for like a trick or like yeah a
John to make me feel good like so I
don't let him like eat my coochie and
like do all that like
I'm just very picky like
is that you're doing it just purely for
the money
and I consider like
well I charge people like I'm not it's
not my job but like if you're in like if
you know that you're not that cute if
you're not cute or you're older older
being like Oh guy like that you're gonna
probably have to pay for
um to be in the presence of a pretty
girl or something like they're not gonna
just let you just sit there and like and
[ __ ] on them or like be with them for
free like I don't know
sorry
are drugs a part of your life huh are
drugs a part of your life
yeah I do crystal
but gambling is the most the worst
addiction that's your biggest rice
that's why I look like this like I look
a mess because
I haven't been home I'll be on like on
the go at the Casitas but being it's
there's some Savages like my whole uh my
whole Mercedes-Benz like probably six
months ago it got stolen from a friend
in front of there they towed the whole
car away and then sold it to somebody
and then the guy tried to make me buy
try to sell it to me back because he had
bought it from somebody
but they towed it away how much money
will you spend in there because the
Casitas are like an underground gambling
I forget for EDD I was getting 1500
every two weeks and it would be gone in
like probably an hour in an hour
um
yeah you got it bad yeah
I do and then when you're making money
on the internet
yeah so you'll burn that as well yeah
but I haven't really been doing dates or
anything like
um I'll be
I did since I learned the game how to do
the the tap tap and I kind of depend on
that like I really don't so it's like a
guy gotta have a lot of money or like
have money for me to want to come out of
like out of the place other than that
I'll be yeah you're not making money in
the Casitas yeah you can't like because
there's there's guys that's that one
that there's older guys and oh I see
you're making money if you can see it
yeah I see it yes I understand I just
walk around and like
they'll either take me home with them or
like give me money to play and then when
I lose I don't want to leave with them
what was the best example of a loving
relationship you saw as a young girl
that I saw yeah your parents
no no
[Music]
um
my dad yeah I never been in
um a house like my mom and my dad
together yeah
um
[Music]
my mom she has lupus and
she's a diabetic
and my daddy my dad he he took he he um
well he didn't he propositioned me like
and my mom heard it on the phone before
so yeah
your dad proposition propositioned you
for a while yeah it wasn't he's on my
he's my sister's ass but my mom still
was like when she heard it like yeah
because you remember when Church
problems was out and so like this and
then I was doing crack my me and my mom
she was we was doing crack together
so this is when chirp phones was out and
he when he was asking me to suck his
dick or like proposition me he had he
was on the button and my mom heard
everything
heard him trying to like probably yeah
were you having
that kind of relationship with him no
but she heard him like
yeah
was there any sexual abuse in your
childhood yeah
yeah
and
yeah okay
um
but I can't I don't really remember
I don't know if I try to I'm blocking it
out but
like recently when I was in jail you
know how you have dreams I don't know
you have dreams a lot you dream a lot
and I was I was dreaming a lot that like
my dad was um that my dad sexually
abused me even though my step dad did
but not my real dad like I don't
remember my real dad doing it but I I
was having dreams I had dreams of it
right that doesn't mean it's necessarily
true but it
just because you dreamed it doesn't mean
it's necessarily true yeah right but it
could be as well yeah yeah
um being in the Casitas
like I got raped in in my ass like
this guy [ __ ] he took me home and
because I wanted to take a shower and
eat and so he offered me and before he
never did nothing so this but the second
time
I guess
um
um after I got the shower he had a
little peanut butter and jelly sandwich
I told him I kept telling him how much I
love peanut butter and jelly and how
much I haven't went to sleep so when I
got there he had the little bed made up
in the peanut butter and jelly sandwich
and like a drink made for me a soda so
I ate it and then I drank I'll start
drinking the soda and I was like telling
him to sew the tasty weird so he gave me
orange juice instead so I drank the
orange juice you know that really that
really throws the taste off like orange
juice there's something in the drink
yeah like if they put something in your
drink like a Sit it'll really you
wouldn't be able to tell because it's
already it's the flavor is so strong
yeah
so I drank all the oranges that's the
last thing I really remember and I
remember I woke up in his car parked
down the street from his house and he
wasn't even in a car so I just got up
eventually and he let I was with him
from like
he picked me up Thursday and and when I
woke up it was like Sunday
but when I woke up everything was like
in a cloud it was just like it was crazy
I thought I was so far away
and I wasn't even far I was like on
Florence I and I thought I was really
far from Western
but
so I eventually got out his car got out
the car and started walking and then um
my butt it started hurting so this guy
he saw me like into distress so he
offered me a ride so I got a ride back
to the the place you know where the guy
worked and I started telling these
people the story of how um my my butt my
[ __ ] hurt or whatever so as the day
started going past my it got swollen to
like the size of a tangerine so they had
a girls one of the girls checked in to
make sure I would see if I was telling
the truth like but who would want to lie
about that like why would I want to set
that rumor up about myself
and
I didn't say that he did because I don't
remember the sexual part I just remember
bits and pieces and I was in his cares
like I was with him so you know come two
and two
but I had to go to the hospital I ended
up going to the hospital and they said I
had GHB in my system
so I'm thinking he put that in a drink
yeah most likely date rape drug right
and yeah I had a lot of like just and
then the other day
I had to go to the hospital because
um this guy gave me a pill and he told
me it was Sudafed and it was a it was an
m30 it was a freaking Oxycontin
you know I actually found it yeah yeah
it's like synthetic heroin like yeah I
could have he could have killed me
like but yeah what is it about the
streets that is so attracting
um the gambling the drugs gambling and
yes the gambling and the drags mostly
but what is it about gambling and or
drugs the winning part is my mom was
like is she's like you better off
smoking crack because this is way worse
like then
yeah doing personal math is worth no no
the gambling like the gambling is worse
than drugs yeah like I don't even
relieve too much I could do without the
drugs but it's just the gambling like
I'll do anything to gamble like
literally like
um
and you have how many kids one daughter
just one she's 21 and
so I've been in her life because I'm
young and I can't raise no kid like at
14 15. so I let her be with her dad's
mom with the grandma and then so now
she's older and I'm trying to get in
touch with her and stuff and she she um
she's all
she's all on Facebook she put she posted
a picture of me and she was like and she
wrote something on the picture like
here's the mom that I never always had
or something like just basically saying
I was never there for her like I
abandoned her and then she's like she's
like she's disrespectful she was calling
me she was just like calling me out like
she gonna beat my ass and like she's
like they they brainwashed her to make
her think that I didn't want her
when they ran away with her
like I let her go there to go stay with
them for you know
and they [ __ ] left with her and I
didn't have no way like and I'm young 15
14 15 and run a run I'm already around
I'm running away and so I couldn't like
just go find her she don't understand
that she just think I abandoned her
you're a kid as well yeah
and then she she wrote me on Facebook a
whole bunch of horrible stuff like
she was like I don't have a mom or a dad
like and she's she posted my pictures
and
like just some bad stuff
and I just and I started I started
talking back bad stuff to her
yeah
if you had your life to live over again
what would you have done differently
um
I haven't I don't know
but I told her that I I disowned her
like she said some hurtful stuff
and like so I told her she didn't have a
mom or a dad now like and I said maybe
if I would have listened to my dad
and or whatever and and went to school I
wouldn't be my maybe your dad would
still be alive and and I wouldn't be
having lived like this if I didn't have
you so I tried to hurt her back like
is your gambling addiction
similar to your drug addiction no how do
they compare you know
yeah the excitement
it's like a it's like a drug like when
you do drugs you try to you trying to
chase that first high like and you're
never gonna get that first time like so
how it Wheels you in is like oh when
you're playing and you win big or
whatever so that first big win like when
I had one like 1200 plan you're trying
to get that to happen again huh yeah
yeah exactly so that's what God had got
me hooked and then you just you're not
gonna never really
go back to that
to get that much it's hard to get to a
high amount have you tried to stop yeah
so yesterday like the whole the whole
Tap House is mad at me today and
yesterday because
um I put five dollars in and I went up
to fourteen hundred dollars and I didn't
cash out I kept playing and I eventually
I shot all my money out I lost it all
and they were all mad at me like
and I don't understand I'd be like it's
not your money like I lost my own money
they wanted you to walk out of winter
yeah and I'll be too greedy like and
then what got what messed it up was when
I asked what was the the cash out limit
they said it was no limit so I just kept
going and going and going and lost it
and so that's why I'm poor right now
that's why this the struggle is hard are
you would you describe yourself as happy
no no
um
no I take psych meds for
um bipolar like I'm suicidal oh really
what makes you suicidal but just um is
it just something yeah I can
I just yeah I can't take certain stuff
like how a regular person could take
like like for instance I try to kill
myself when
um my first apartment my white friend he
got me he got me apartment and then
but he co-signed and so he sent me a
letter like
um
I'm tired of your mess because I got it
real far away from him because I don't
see you anyway so I don't know how
you're gonna pay for your rent and so
like that same night I tried to kill
myself
um my mom like my mama had a heart
attack
and I thought she's gonna die so I said
I told her if she died I was gonna kill
myself like
so that's tight like it's just it's and
then
I want to die every day
serious uh I hate myself
foreign
people pick on me like they bully me I'm
telling you like I'm not racist but no
like none of the black girls inside of
the places I go they like they don't I
mean they don't like me they just like
talk about me like they talk about me
because I'm like skinny like
I just don't
I don't feel pretty I don't think I'm
pretty people tell me I'm pretty or
something I don't see the same thing
you're beautiful but if you don't see
yourself that way no everyone in the
world can tell you that and it won't
change anything um
when I was doing drugs like guys would
like talk talk to me like the drug
dealer like the people that was selling
the drugs
um so I would I would talk crazy to them
or if it was bad dope I would go back
and talk crazy so I did that one day
over there by the Nicholsons and they
[ __ ] they
um I don't know I don't remember what
they did like I just know I woke up in
the hospital and the next day they put
me in a coma and knocked my tooth out
because my teeth is missing right here
yeah I'm getting knocked out by his like
five guys that happened recently it
happened like probably a couple of years
ago like in my twin I was probably like
20 something when I was doing crack
a little bit like one of the drug
dealers did it because I was talking
[ __ ] to him
I woke up in the hospital
Barbie what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
that you can't trust everybody and
everybody's not your friend
but I just I don't know
like my car got stolen
and to like my car the my Mercedes-Benz
got stolen then like after just recently
I got I had got a Lexus and I invited
this girl from the the tap tap to my
house to spend the night and I woke up
and she was she left she stole my cars
but I got the car back but they took the
Cadillac converter and I'll have the key
but I got it towed back to my house
but
I don't I don't do nothing to anybody I
promise you and they just pick on me so
like I'd rather be dead sometimes
then to get pics on
it and like I really I'm against like
bullies I don't like bullies because
that's like most of the cause of people
like people that want to kill themselves
and me being suicidal I know how I feel
like it's like people just think
I don't know that
like I can't just rub something like
when people talk about me I really it
gets to me and I can't just smile it off
or like how a regular person could he
makes
I wouldn't want to kill myself that's an
easy way out for me
yeah Barbie thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you I wish you
the best of luck out there okay stay out
of the Casitas
you know
like thank you